rompiendo con la política de no
injerencia en los asuntos internos en
sus diez países miembros los líderes de
la asociación de naciones del sudeste
asiático asean se reunieron en yakarta
para discutir una solución pacífica para
la crisis política y social en mi alma
desde el golpe militar del pasado 1 de
febrero la nación está sumida en una
espiral de violencia derivada de la
brutal represión de las manifestaciones
pro democracia para convengan siento así
de mianmar asueto y aunque está capa la
situación actual en mianmar es
inaceptable y no puede continuar hay que
poner fin a la violencia y restaurar la
democracia la estabilidad y la paz en
mianmar as tan parte ambiente mianmar
generosa creativa licán ganando por los
precios políticos deben ser liberados
inmediatamente a paz kahn en calidad de
jefe del ejército y no como líder de
mianmar el general min hollande aterrizó
en la capital indonesia donde escuchó
los reclamos de la asean tras el
encuentro los líderes se mostraron
satisfechos con los cinco puntos
acordados con el jefe de la junta
militar pero no están claras aún las
vías para lograrlo consenso de la asean
sobre mianmar
inmediata de la violencia todas las
partes ejercen moderación diálogo entre
todas las partes enviado especial de la
asean ayuda humanitaria para mí al mar
enviado especial para conocer a todas
las partes sin embargo general birmano
no respondió explícitamente a las
demandas de detener la matanza de
manifestantes pese a los llamados a la
liberación de los presos políticos entre
ellos a la líder birmana and sand suit
si no hubo una respuesta contundente
mientras tanto en las calles birmanas
continuaban las protestas mientras los
líderes de la asean están hablando hoy
en indonesia de una reducción de la
violencia con ming aun lane sus tropas
están matando gente dentro de mianmar
tenemos que esperar y ver si los
militares ilegales no los escuchan
cuáles serán los próximos movimientos de
la asean si bien no se les permitió su
participación en la cumbre el gobierno
civil de unidad birmano acoge con
satisfacción el consenso alcanzado como
un primer esfuerzo internacional para
aliviar la crisis en mianmar